welcome to this video playing Mata ma
from Sweden yes do we get the bank oh no
that chick been only that's a fairly
popular opening in blitz chess more
muscle than than in tournament chess I
think one reason is that it is
relatively easy to dash out quite a
number of moves there's black get them
play quickly okay i want to see going to
do h 5h for fighting for the dark
squares i guess hmm okay no hmm then
okay if you go to g6 early you usually
do this with the intention of playing
age 5 h form if you don't have this idea
um frankly it doesn't make any sense to
to place what is it doing here don't get
it we should be five I just go f4 and
you have lost tons of time and f5
blunders piece due to the fork on g4
right age for maybe maybe thats that's
the point of all this
how weird is on that okay night h floor
is what he wants to do I guess I cannot
move my two nite cannot move this night
as f for good hang Queen Queen edge
forms not a real problem ok I think I
can start with that ok f5 so e five
checks you will play a form a strange as
it looks seems to be seems to be ok fun
very weird ok I cannot go if five so i
have to play something like that and
really remarkable so a force probably
premature it and you have to play Queen
d2 I guess
yeah this is not good at all how do I
players here 93 maybe I can trade some
stuff off I can check it for you right i
have to head to take the other night if
i play 93 editor you can take a genetic
set for him or this one
wow what a rubbish game what did that do
in this game for right yeah after didn't
air force was really premature them
huh yeah well black black setup was
really just bad but I absolutely did not
refute it
I can absolutely not defend this
position h3 is completely gone
Knight f3 will just take g2 and train i
therefore again yeah wow yeah it's just
totally lost staff in an episode no no
cannot even hope for some swinger
no okay white bears are in session there
are 0 all of them out of three yeah
that's kind of frustrating especially
after such a bad opening from like this
is totally misplaced but I f was just to
just completely offer what I played here
just totally awful it gives it makes it
gives those pieces sense and this was a
very bad decision I have to play em yeah
22 I mean not f4 I guess just maybe just
just something like that and this is
just a bit better for white due to the
space no white is better because those
pieces are misplaced it's nothing super
great but what is why this better those
pieces are just wrong there but f voice
is just a mistake I guess and unless
there's something great that I have here
but now it all makes some sense those
pieces do do do make sense and I don't
need to be so so I don't need to explode
as quickly as i did but it gets some
Gant f5 is strong it's just strong I
cannot go e five because of because of
this and yeah I have no moves it just
lost almost lost their I don't don't
think I can can I put this yeah now
everything gets into action the root
gets into action this is on the pawn
down not in a practical game yeah
Queenie seven is also strong move Knight
edge for is good yeah then that just it
just really really bad yeah yeah he
played that nine i th for this is it's
just terrible yeah I made his misplaced
pieces are now all good and this is why
why this f4 move was wasn't a good idea
maybe I should have actually now that I
think of it
I should have played Queen d2 here to
prevent to prevent Bishop g5 and this is
this is this is much better actually in
comparison here those play here those
pieces don't make any sense on g6 and
age five yeah I don't know it should be
at least a bit better for watch it to
the space if you go nigh to g6 you
normally do it to play without
cancelling and go h5 which you didn't do
what um the thing is I really have to
remember this playing with f4 it's not a
good idea here because it gives those
pieces lots of scope here all of a
sudden yeah completely misplayed that
and remarkable how bad it was yeah I
mean I couldn't really I couldn't even
put up a fight which is just a terribly
bad position Wow okay thanks for
watching